you might have noticed that that's a new
look for our thumbnails the guests name
on top well there's nothing else to tell
you about this podcast except that you
are about to have a good old time so
let's get into it
ladies and gentlemen Tom Segura yeah
dude
what's up guys Tom on very short notice
yesterday I have terrible news
on our podcast channel the highest the
highest viewed episode is Bert Kreischer
oh damn this sucks dude so how many
views did again YouTube he's over
700,000 you know he's drinking a gallon
of kool-aid a day now so that's um we
might not have a much longer about what
why is he doing that um I don't know he
said he brushes his teeth first thing
around midday so why does he do that why
does he shower in the pool
what happened was I like I have one
right like to hide it's a half gallon
and I thought I thought every human
being that you see with one of these has
water in it that's what is literally
what I thought and I've seen him with it
and I'm like good for him I just didn't
say anything and then we were doing a
podcast and I thought I saw someone I
was like the [ __ ] is in there he was
like oh cool eight and I was like now
and then it's like yeah man I go wait
you drink a half gallon of kool-aid he
goes what I try to drink two of these a
day I have a drinking kool-aid since I
was nine you drink that much every day
but when's the last time you drank
kool-aid probably like like years ago in
high school when we're stoned it's
pocket-sized right yeah that's not I
mean of course everyone's had it so
let's get right into it I am dying to
know your philosophy when it comes to
posting videos of guys hitting their
balls out of there
Sol's on Twitter look man I am I don't
think twice about it and I honestly you
know when I've been posting stuff like
that for years like anything like
outrageous is somebody said like I post
videos the way you've done stunts like
I'm just like yeah man this is insane
I'm gonna share it and it always upsets
a certain segment of follow like they'll
let you know
you know unfollowed and they'll be like
what the [ __ ] and I'm just like look if
this is weeding out weak people then
it's just to me it's a sign to keep
doing it you know like if something is
that alarming I want to share it okay
look listen let's examine what this guy
did he put his own balls into his own
[ __ ] and then pushed them out and
then you learn I learned that he
actually did this on New Year's when you
drop the ball nice it's [ __ ]
brilliant it's really it is and I had
already seen it like it was I believe
Eric Andre sent me this video however I
saw it and I immediately tried to tell
me you didn't try it yourself oh yeah I
just don't have that hang I mean so
anyway I had that guy on my podcast
it comes out tomorrow Thursday so it'll
be available perfect this will be the
night so he you know of course I had a
million questions and he's like yeah you
got to have you got to be blessed with
like some natural ball hang and then you
can kind of work on stretching it a
little more but his his sack we if he
lays down it it's basically almost
touches his [ __ ]
so he's a real [ __ ] soldier man yeah
he really mean I've got the hang it's
just it's I couldn't I can get my balls
up to my [ __ ] [ __ ] but when it comes
to actually jamming him in there that
hurts
I I imagine it would I mean to me I
don't know about how you feel about your
your balls being you know
played with or whatever I like a light
tug one anything more than that I'm like
whoa hey [ __ ] chill out like I am NOT
I'm not the type that wants its super
aggressive with the balls you know and I
have kids and when you hope I have
little kids but you hold your kids their
legs are always swinging like crazy I
see white I [ __ ] start sweating when
they just graze your nuts so I can't
imagine what it'd be like to push them
in your [ __ ]
this dude is such a savage I'm willing
to bet that you don't know where this
conversation is headed and before you
find out I'm going to tell you something
really important about your [ __ ] and
my absolute favorite product that I've
been introduced to by this podcast it's
called hello tushy calm and it operates
like a pressure cleaner for your
butthole after you poop because let me
admit I used to be one of those people
who just used toilet paper and then
walked around like it wasn't a big
problem but secretly I had to go back to
the bathroom just to be sure and I would
wipe again and I'd see stuff on the
paper but not anymore thanks to hello
tushy calm it's a big day okay now
there's a little knob on the side and
what it does he turn it and it sends
water blasting into your [ __ ] I'm
gonna do it right now yeah oh yeah oh
yeah now I can turn it up a little more
but I will never be able to turn it up
all the way because the power is
incredible and when I get done that's
plenty
now there's nothing to wipe I mean sure
I can wipe just for the satisfaction of
knowing that there's going to be nothing
to see on the paper which I really do
enjoy ya see nothing
so there it is on top of making your
butthole healthier so you don't have to
worry about stuff like hemorrhoids and
colon cancer at least not as much as the
other people with the toilet paper it's
also a great way to save the world I
mean look I got toilet paper
it's basically for decoration because I
don't mean it I have
hello tushy calm and if you go - hello -
she calm / Steve oh you're gonna get 10%
off your order and I'm telling you your
butthole is gonna thank me so one more
time 10% off your order
if you go - hello Toshi calm / Steve oh
and you're welcome he will put his balls
in his ass and then get [ __ ] with them
in his [ __ ] oh wow he sent me some
other videos that are pretty cool you'll
be like wow he can really do a lot with
that thing
III would love to see them now the main
reason that I asked as fascinating as it
is and and I agree with you know I like
just letting it ride with shocking stuff
but like if you were to put that on
Instagram if you were to put that on
Facebook
what makes Twitter so different that you
can just get away with that and nobody's
outraged dude I'm glad they're allowing
it I mean I know that that's where like
the adult performers have thrived like
all of them have stories about just even
like the women posing in thongs and
they're like Instagram just deleted my
account I had [ __ ] 2 million
followers and they just deleted it
because they posed in a thong or
something I don't know I mean there's
there's so many like different points of
view on the censorship and and the you
know the stands or the practices and
ultimately we don't get to say much
because these are privately held
companies that can do what they want
it doesn't feel consistent though I'll
tell you that it does not feel
consistent and I'm just talking about
this outrageous stuff it's like I had a
[ __ ] video that
so Graham took down and sent me have you
ever post something where they go your
video or your poll and in our Community
Guidelines yeah yeah yeah dude I posted
a highlight because when we do pie you
know we do a bunch of podcasts we'll do
like a 20 30 second promo right like we
pick a moment from the show and it'll be
like new episode and it's a it's a 30
second promo so I had one for my Spanish
podcast
so the post is all in Spanish and I'm on
the phone with my mom and I'm reading
her slang from Venezuela my mom's from
Peru so I'm teaching her this is how you
say these things this is the way the
expression the slang in Venezuela and as
I'm reading it to her she's reacting
she's like oh my kits always like we're
talking in Spanish and I say it to her
and she's like oh my god this is crazy
and I go yeah she goes this must be your
good friend that sent you this and she
says it in the masculine term right like
amigo and I say no it's a woman and she
goes woof prostitute she actually says
prostitute and I die laughing that my
mom assumes that a prostitute emailed me
these sayings that's it
that's the promo and Instagram after
like a month and I get was up for a
month and a half took it down and so and
I was like why I had my reps reach out
to their contact and they were like they
can't tell you what like okay I mean
that kind of [ __ ] enrages right that
that that's hey guys why is that a
violation guy not only do is it enraging
that they take it down but that there's
zero explanation like what is it that
happened in here that's not okay
right they don't tell you it's always
the case with me where it's like weeks
or months later and then all of a sudden
I see that there's been a violation when
the bottle cup the bottle cap challenge
was was wildly popular I filmed an
incredible video where I I kicked off
the cap it was
spinning alright but I did it with my
dick and and I'm just awesome well thank
you and I very carefully blurred it so
there was nothing to see but then it
lasted for weeks or months and then it
came down it anyway broke my heart
because that was the most liked thing I
had ever put on Instagram
I bet though it's like a concerted
effort of an accumulation of people
getting rapport rapport and I could only
a suit like with yours obviously it's
people you know say you know being
[ __ ] at [ __ ] about it and just
being like well yeah I know that he did
it with his dick even if you can't you
know which is just so lame with mine I
had to assume that it's like this
Venezuelan contingency that was
basically reporting that I'm calling
Venezuelan women prostitute like it's so
silly and then and then to think that
the people who work at Instagram were to
see those and what is it an algorithm
where it hits a certain number and they
just go strike it or did somebody watch
that and agree with it which is more
insane to me you know right well it's
crazy like some companies do that we
were selling merch over in Canada and
then in the next day they shut us all
down and they kept their money and I
called and I said hey like what's the
deal you know I was like Shopify and
they said you shut down all of our money
and they took it and they said oh we
can't tell you why but we're holding
onto it for 180 days to see to see what
the deal is with this and and again they
couldn't tell you what the problem was
and they just kept all your money I mean
people doing that and then going and we
can't tell you why somebody there can
somebody there speaks the same language
right they're looking at the why off the
computer they just don't want to tell
you yeah
you had immigrant like have you had
what's it called customs flex on you in
in you know where I've been flexed on
the hardest is Canada first a dude I
would not be allowed in Canada under any
circumstances if I did not have a
Canadian passport you have a Canadian
passport yeah because my mom was born in
Canada so that makes me Canadian and my
dad was born in America so that makes me
American and I I was born in England so
that makes me British you have three
passports three passports all totally
valid yeah it's pretty awesome but back
to this thing with the Twitter and then
you know like I'm particularly like like
just doesn't focused on this issue
because as I might have told you the
last time I saw you I've got this
exciting new comedy special and what I
did with it was to edit footage into it
of the stories I'm telling in the in the
act so yeah like sure enough I'm on
stage but as I'm telling these stories
you see the footage of the stories that
I'm telling and a lot of it is pretty
explicit stuff you know I like you see
my Weiner from time to time and as I go
about figuring out how to market it how
to promote it the question becomes like
okay where is it appropriate and how is
it appropriate to disseminate footage of
my Weiner you know and this is
particularly a touchy topic these days
so like one thing I thought have you
heard of the community app this is the
thing where the celebrities say text me
like as if it's gonna be like some
personal conversation have it and I
[ __ ] I they they stopped asking me
just to you they were like texting me
daily like you should send a message
very useful for touring because it does
break everything down geographically
it's like hey guys I'm coming to your
town like I see a lot of value in that
but we're not touring now so the only
reason I signed up for this community
app was oh maybe I can put [ __ ] on there
and text it to people directly that
isn't safe for Instagram so I sign up
with the community I got my point person
and I [ __ ] share with him this
caption from my Instagram poster I'm
about to announce my community phone
number the guy says yeah thumbs up man
go for it the caption read if you are
over 18 and won't be upset by really
naughty stuff that I can't post on here
because they'll kick me off then shoot
me a text and I'll send that crazy [ __ ]
to you direct right and I'm right I
converted like I converted 42,000 cell
phone numbers out of that one post so it
like off to a pretty good start and it
has been confirmed everybody who sends
me a text on the community app will get
some wildly [ __ ] up [ __ ] before it
becomes public in the rest of the world
knows about it so go ahead and shoot me
a text at 3 2 3 5 7 7 6 9 5 2 and expect
some wild [ __ ] in the next week or two
yeah that's why I wanted to ask you
about [ __ ] ball because you're just
like I mean there's got to be some
people under 18 and follow you on
twitter that day that i posted that one
of the first comments I saw was easiest
unfollow of all time who is the guy the
guy who's sitting there and he just got
the gigantic black wiener yeah you're
selling t-shirts for to raise money for
his funeral or whatever is that yeah
that was the what's his name would that
dude would and but that but the shirt
was a totally it's just his face by then
everybody had become familiar with the
memes so his face was like enough of a
nod to people to people who knew it
which turned out to be a lot of people
because that meme was so
we shared and it was just his face and
it said wash your hands right yeah but
that no we yeah that we were able to pay
for his his headstone and send his kids
money to was this a guy was in a guy who
died of kovat no no that that dude you
know he died at having a large [ __ ] he
he actually died he had a heart attack
completely unrelated to any of this in
2016 and the you know I I like other
people when cuz now like the meme got
played out you know it's kind of like
but when cut when the quarantine started
remember like every day I don't know if
you around any like text threads were
like your friends were like texting the
memes of that dude it was kind of like
everybody was excited to see what the
new variation of the meme was of that
dude and I started to go like who is
this guy and then vice wrote an article
on him and sort of hinted at who he was
I contacted the photographer who took
that famous picture of him and he kind
of pointed me in the right direction of
the family to try to figure this whole
thing out that was a professional photo
shoot prestigious photographer who shot
that iconic photo sort of feels like it
is yeah but that dude you know it's one
of those things where when you get to
know the real story you know it like it
changes everything for I don't know if
you feel that way we're like I don't
know you you see an image of somebody
it's like when someone's famous and you
just know like the faint like you know
whatever LeBron James or Charlize Theron
they're like it's just like it's a name
it's an image but then if you meet them
and hang out with them you're like oh
and it just it changes your whole
perspective on the person you go it's
not your actor now that's like it's like
I talked to him about [ __ ] fishing or
something you know you just you change
so this guy we all know him as like
sitting on the edge of his bed with his
huge dick but then
you know I talked to his fiancee for
[ __ ] an hour and then the advice
actually did this follow-up story where
they they they kind of like covered like
who he was in depth and then now you see
the meme and you just makes me sad you
know because now I I feel like I know
the story Eddie was a good guy yeah he
was a good guy he did this he did the
the new thing one time what was the
purpose of doing the nerd thing he was
gonna lose the house that he grew up in
that was passed down to him he couldn't
pay the mortgage so it was like a quick
way to make like whatever a couple grand
and keep paying the mortgage on it so
you know was it for my god was it for
like big dicks if I can it was like big
gay dicks or something like that
the photographer who's in that piece the
guy who shoots out his boss said that he
used to see the big black dude at the
gym and he said he got friendly with him
and then one day you know assiduity he
said that that that guy the big the big
dude was super like shy and
uncomfortable with doing it like he he
could tell you know it wasn't like his
regular work but yeah I don't know
comfortable in the picture as I recall
the picture in the picture right so
insurgency never had any like it like
for all the things you put on Twitter
that are just like wildly adult only
there's never even been a hint of
consequences or concerns
I mean I've received enormous backlash
from people following me right or just
like you know I hate you I want to put
bleach in my eyes I'm unfollowing you
what the [ __ ] is this why would you you
know okay like elements and stuff but I
just always I
think of them as you know disposable and
I'm sure I try to move on it seems a
little bit like it's on Twitter because
for whatever reason they're okay with it
yeah you can search like any type of
ridiculous
hardcore search term on Twitter and you
will find multiple accounts that that's
all the way posts you know Twitter
doesn't I don't think they restrict
anything as far as I know but Instagram
of course which is owned by Facebook has
a way different set of guy ironically
it's Facebook that has been in all that
hot water for deciding that like right
they will not call out fake claims in
political ads and you're like what do
you they're like these are knowingly
false and they're like we're not gonna
get involved and Twitter will say hey
guys the president is bullshitting you
yes and Twitter will say like yeah if
you want to put your balls in your ass
don't [ __ ] lie to us like I feel like
you guys have the glasses going I just
picked up some glasses I have various
ones I'm gonna try them on these are my
1960s FBI agent you let me know what you
think all right I like it right this is
a civil rights violation you look like a
shooting range
you got the head gear on and I glaze
all right right right it's very who shot
JFK somehow God you guys are so much
sharper now that I have these on
do you actually require prescription
glasses for for reading and for screens
they're much better for screens for me I
don't want them to like drive or
anything but walk around but yeah I'm a
prescription on top for distance and a
little bit of magnification on bottom
for reading hello and I can't [ __ ]
read I can't see [ __ ] without it it's
alarming bifocal it's progressive
progressive folk oh yeah totally random
question but what's up with this with
Karen where did where did Karen come
from Costco Karen Karen is just the new
word for [ __ ] it is it's the new name
for white [ __ ] which I there's plenty
of out there I don't mean it is kind of
a perfect name to describe what they're
talking about you know like I mean it's
the kid we always used to say that you
know it's the can I talk to the managers
here right and then huh that's a lot of
words so like what name best embodies
I'd like to speak to the manager feels
like it is Karen okay okay
Karen's kind of perfect for that is it I
suppose you say I'd like to talk to the
manager that calls to my mind I don't
you know who I am
could that be boiled down into one
that's a different person
right right we should we should name I
think it's a guy though for sure a girl
I know a very [ __ ] male thing yeah I
don't know dude I know he's like
Lumbergh on the on Reese Witherspoon why
I want to say right right I mean she
said that to the police the highest
level of saying that right like the
[ __ ] hostess at Ruth's Chris when she
said it to a cop right you [ __ ] know
who I am not to get like you know on to
politics but do you have any concern
that the actual profession of police
officer is just so unattractive now that
we're actually gonna just not have cops
I don't think we're gonna we're not
gonna have cops but it definitely is not
an attractive position I mean I I think
it would be fascinating to see the stats
in like six months or a year about like
how many people in the in this year was
I gotta sign up for the Academy yeah
it's like I'm sure there's a standard
number every year like next year they'll
be like oh that's down 70% right kind of
like kind of like naming your baby Karen
it's gotta be things that fell off in
2020 categories gotta be a [ __ ] a
couple cool women named Karen or like
god dammit I have an old friend named
Karen you know I've actually never known
sweet I mean I think a good fella's you
know all right I think is that kids
signing up her parents signing up their
children for a little league football
with all the CTE stuff yeah like I think
that football and like cops are two
things that I suppose down baseball's in
trouble real baseball because baseball's
been on a decline for decades just in in
now you know if you go to early nineteen
hundred's even through the forties
fifties sixties they that's what I
called America's pastime you know it's
like people love baseball this country
it went on a steady decline which some
people kind of correlate with the way
that it went on a crazy incline in Latin
America you know it became like more
like a the sport thrives elsewhere
because a lot of our best athletes
stopped playing baseball like kids who
are lies that that it just became it
became less cool less pop when a kid was
a great athlete in let's say the 90s and
he had his choice of sports to play he
just wasn't going for baseball like he
was gonna play football he was gonna
play basketball you know even now it's
like what is like a an elite athlete who
is [ __ ] 14 playing chances are it's
gonna be the ticket Oh basketball is the
[ __ ] like the the only thing about
basketball is you also for the most part
why I'm can be like that frame you have
to be a monster
you have to be oh I'm 610 which is like
you're such an anomaly at that point
anyway right yeah football has been on
the I don't know I feel like I've always
felt like even though I'm sure
statistically numbers are down I always
thought that the the apprehension behind
Little League football is kind of
ridiculous to me
you know I'm somebody that played
football from fourth grade through 12th
grade and you know when you're playing
with like so many kids I'm saying like
when the pool of talent is so big you
rarely are in a in a game where you're
getting [ __ ] up well like you do at
high level sports the counter-argument
to that is that at that young age your
brain is still undeveloped or you know
much more like yes I hear that argument
but but my thing to that is like dude oh
all the games I played in from like like
I said from fourth grade on it's like I
could tell you that most games you don't
have holy [ __ ] contact in right fourth
grade fifth grade sixth grade because
that savage like anomaly player he's not
even in every County Rhaego like like
like most kids in fifth grade they walk
up and they go like that and like they
they barely wrap up the offensive line
of the defensive line are still gonna
collide every parent against it but what
with what amount of force yeah that's
true but we can we can agree that
footballs going away now are we worried
about gymnastics
what about like did you did you see the
athlete a film on Netflix I turned it
off because I was trying to wind down
about 20 minutes and I was like you know
um I kind of feel like crying so I think
I'm gonna turn this off I mean dude it's
just a it's just a well produced like
really compelling documentary which I
think
signals a real decline in the future of
generic domestics I know
dude have you ever read the stats I mean
this is a totally like that that whole
story is just unbelievably depressing
see the level of that just abuse but the
neglect involved where they were
actually I just put that in the [ __ ]
file cabinet but have you ever read
about the number of concussions and
injuries in soccer in in like little
league soccer in this country oh really
I I wonder because I know that rugby is
actually pretty safe and I think that's
because they're not wearing helmets at
all I think that there's a strong
argument for football having been
considerably more safe back in the day
when it was just like a [ __ ] stupid
leather trying to sleeve over your head
because I don't know it's like that
it's it's exactly like boxing is way
more [ __ ] dangerous than MMA because
with the small MMA glove right you're
gonna injure your hand if you punch
something but with that big old [ __ ]
boxing glove who cares and it's so heavy
that that's why boxing is killing
killing people and not in boxing has 12
ounce gloves and yeah you could [ __ ]
somebody and their hands are super
wrapping the comparison the parallel is
that the 12 ounce boxing glove really
does damage to a man's head much like
that bulky ass NFL football helmet
whereas the MMA glove it's you not
seeing all that all of this
a lot of football injuries to the head
are completely avoidable when you when
you break down the technique that caused
these injuries a lot of them nobody's
waiting with their head in a rugby if
you play football the way that like
you're coached to play football you
would have a fraction of the injuries
what's interesting though if you look at
the soccer stuff is every year people
die playing soccer and every year people
have innumerable concussions playing
Little League and high school soccer
because they get kicked in the head
elbowed in the head kneed in the head
they get [ __ ] up and it's never
reported like it's never the headline
story I mean the real sports has done a
profile on it the HBO show that like
there's a lot of injuries playing soccer
but it's not as salacious as the
headlines for so where do I find this
this soccer injury documentary that
sounds great just google it there's just
tons of information about it but I'm
saying real sports the HBO series has
profiled it before I had the whole
episode about that I was crazy they're
passing kicked balls 50 yards down down
the field with their head it's like it's
just traveling and it's not that
consumed night hearing Tom complain
about that you know it's it's it's the
collisions you know the collisions are
what what caused it I what a bro tom is
like we haven't even talked about is
it's a comedy special ball hog no
there's no glasses on of course I will
mention that in the intro to the podcast
your your Netflix special ball hog on
his Netflix telling you like they're
pretty guarded about like analytics and
stuff like do they tell you like hey man
like good retention you know like this
first this was the first time I've done
force this is my fourth special with
them and they've never most I ever got
before was like it's doing great uh-huh
is there anything else and they're like
nope good job you're like great thanks
man literally that's it that is it and
you're like you can't tell me anything
no and this time they gave me numbers
they gave me retention rates they gave
me they said that in another few months
we will do a call where they will tell
me regions like they'll tell me areas
where like where maybe areas that I'm
ignoring like they did tell me sorry
they told me some countries already
where they're like you should be
considering doing a tour in these
countries and they tell you some
surprised ones they'll be like
you might be surprised to hear this but
it did really well here and then they
tell you the opposite they'll be like
you know where no one's watching your
shits pretty cool you mentioned
something about about Spanish and with
the Instagram post your mom do you
record a Spanish version of the special
as well I'm doing a special in Spanish
for Netflix that I was supposed to shoot
in the fall that obviously we have to
push it now but I'm gonna do it I'm
gonna do one I guess
hopefully sometime next year yeah is it
Felipe Esparza is that right the guy he
does like the same taping I think he did
back to back anyway does one English and
Spanish
yeah he's probably doing that in English
and Spanish night of the special yeah
when you have these different
international regions does that mean
that they're overdubbing a stand-up
comedy special into like you know
Kazakhstan it's all it's all subtitles
like so they Netflix when you deliver a
show or a special will spend like I
don't know what it is eight weeks or
something doing translations and
subtitles into like some insane like
hundred and twelve languages or
something right just actually with my
youtube channel I just invested in
getting subtitles generated for Italian
Portuguese English German I think does
he do Chinese - no because because you
cubes not in China it's banned
ah that's right that's right that would
be awesome though if you're like and my
biggest investment was in Mandarin of
course we're both touring comedians like
a you're just like big theatre guy I
just made the leap to theaters I found
out like the same week we got shut down
but what are you doing business-wise of
course you're very prolific podcaster
I'm sure that do you have any other
hidden revenue streams that are that are
thriving in the pandemic
I mean I I know I've done let's see that
there's all the podcasts there's
obviously like the merchandise business
I signed a book deal so that's a nice a
book thing and then yeah we we we
pitched an animated show that we're we
have two offers on so we're kind of
negotiating on that whose casino night
oh yeah
lots of love to her she's so I just
followed her on Instagram no yeah yeah
so you know that's the thing it's like
something gets taken away and you go
like I gotta figure something else out
you know so for sure right I know that
Scott his ears perked up when you said
merch like how do you do your
fulfillment on the merch side of things
well we hope we hire here that you're
hiring someone to collect all the data
they got the whole email list they have
a humongous email list they're taking
all the money for them are they taking
and and do they do like a licensing deal
do they say like if you will take care
of everything we'll just cut you in a
percentage of what we say a huge
percentage plus all the data and the
data is worth way more the dad is
definitely worth more now so to me it's
like well it's it's it's about whether
or not I'm going to like I'm gonna have
to outsource it in some way like I I'm
you know obviously I'm not going to do
it so it's like it's either like do I
invest in setting up that
you know fulfillment myself with another
company like my build my company to do
it or do I outsource it to somebody else
see I've got Scott and all I can say is
sweet sweet OCD it's a whole other deal
but if you have like an assistant or if
you have somebody like and you want to
have them reach out to me like I can I
can walk them through and help it's not
as hard as you think
I would I would love to offer my
services free of charge to teach whoever
you have because it just gets me to the
core of all these companies that like
reach out to people and they're like
dude like we'll take care of you like
we'll do everything and they're just
gathering hundreds of millions of emails
and and I just said to in layman's terms
it's really quite simple as a
fulfillment house which is just linked
up to Shopify you know it's and you
manage it all on an app you know he's on
with the fulfillment house quite a bit
but you just have to make that
connection between Shopify and the
fulfillment house and it's all automated
the rest of the way and you just keep
ads very simple really
yeah it's so simple and you mentioned
much like it's a good size you know
portion percentage of the revenue like
how often do you come up with new [ __ ]
and put it out well we've done it
different ways you know in the past
we've done things where it's like here's
a new thing let's put out this new thing
like this one item and then another
approach we've done is like develop
let's say six eight ten items drop them
all at once and basically break that up
and do it do it again after a while you
know I mean like let those new items go
see what's a hit
what's a dud writing like basically like
the same I almost I would approach
writing jokes right when you're like
this this killed this didn't so we've
gone we've gone both both ways before
but yeah it's significant numbers men do
dope glasses glasses yeah there's our
dough
yeah I don't think God I'm sorry
what about like charitable causes is
there anything that you're particularly
fired up about getting behind
I mean I've donated to Starlight
Children's Foundation a number of times
you know they take care of like kids
like there they're an organization that
their whole thing is to make like kids
that are in hospitals have like
basically a more comfortable stay they
they buy VR sets for them they get them
like instead of like those standard
gowns that you get they'll get them like
they'll do cool ones with like cartoon
characters or sports teams and they'll
put on like activities for like sick
kids and put their charity link in the
video description West our star
Starlight Children's Foundation men
there are darn light Children's
Foundation and find their link in the
video description below of this video
and watch time Segura's for different
Netflix specials god it makes me jealous
to say that and and share this video so
that it can [ __ ] buy beat Bert
Kreischer for God says when you wake up
you you take a leak right haha I take a
leave many times throughout the night
and you're like when you're like I'm up
once I'm up I wake up without teeth I
got like I got this little [ __ ] thing
and then I go and I take my vitamins on
my b12 under my tongue my what he called
psychiatrist pill my antacid for acid
reflux and and my vitamin D swallow down
brush my teeth and then pop in my teeth
and I'm off why don't you wait like
until midday because in case you come
into contact with somebody you don't
have shitty breath right what I want to
know is why is it as
i-it'll [ __ ] taboo to tell a
[ __ ] when they got bad breath
that's a real question and I know some
people that are like it's it's seriously
right and here's the thing like a couple
of them are friends right I still I
still feel like like I feel like you got
to be like so close you know like I
would say it too
- Bert I would say it's and my wife we
absolutely have a pact that if ever
there's standing that [ __ ] going on that
we'd [ __ ] yeah I've made a solemn
oath to say something yeah but let's be
clear there's different kinds of bad
breath there's the kind of bad breath
like you know okay maybe eight something
maybe something's you know but then
there's that [ __ ] really malicious
bacteria which no amount of brushing is
ever gonna make the [ __ ] order go
away I remember when I was a kid my mom
in the mornings would say oh god your
[ __ ] breath is awful I'd say mom I
just brushed my teeth I wasn't even a
kid I was like 19 I was like mom I just
brush my teeth she's like I don't care
you're [ __ ] Brett and one time I got
in the van with the Jackass guys and we
men says Oh Steve Oh your breath and
then knock so said saying steve-o has
bad breath is like saying we man is
short it's all the time and and like I
didn't understand but but you gotta
floss that's the thing so wait what's
your breath your breath was just always
and I had bacteria in my mouth that
brushing wasn't gonna get it out of
there you got it when you have so it's
so the way to do it if we could ever
muster up the balls to tell somebody
about this odor in their mouth is to say
hey like I think that you have an order
in your mouth you think you're not aware
of and the way to get rid of it is to
floss smell the floss and if it's gnarly
then keep flossing until you can't smell
it anymore
Wow I know now you're now you're as much
of shipra i don't yeah now I'm at like
dude I finally [ __ ] figured it out
thank God only time I feel comfortable
with like a dude who I'm not like close
with saying that would be if he was like
uh
if he was telling me he was about to
like go talk to a chick like he was like
right then I'd like you pop some gum in
your mouth dude that's it it's like
because I know that I'm actually like
helping them in this situation just like
chilling it yeah it does feel like I
don't know I feel like it's like it's
taken like you're insulting you know no
there's a solution to this is is they
have this problem a couple years ago on
the Howard Stern Show and they were
looking up like how to tell somebody
Colgate has an anonymous program where
you can send like a care package to
somebody's house and it's like totally
anonymous and they're like hey you have
bad breath like here your simple steps
on how to use it to like floss your
teeth but like somebody told us about
you and we're just here to help you and
it's totally like I think goes on the
Howard Stern Show because they had some
guy calling and I remember that shirt
but I remember the Colgate program yeah
and I think Gary looked it up and he's
like well they say dude somebody gets it
from like because of me they'll be like
oh I saw it steve-o podcast it's
definitely you the Senate right plus you
know they're definitely gonna see this
because well yeah it's gonna get 800,000
views and survivor so yeah it's gonna be
okay now I mean dude like honestly like
even though I hit you up just yesterday
[ __ ] I bet I haven't been able to wait
to get you on because I think with [ __ ]
if Bert Kreischer is number one then Tom
Segura is gonna be a [ __ ] murderer
it's gonna be a we'll see this could
[ __ ] bomb man let's just hope for the
best
yeah I mean I think that the thing they
hit here then I'll let you go after this
but I want to confess that that before
this this channel was dedicated to
podcasts it was what I referred to as my
second channel and I would put up videos
which were like more on brand so when I
switched over to podcasting the
algorithm was very healthy it was like
you know all the content was super
well-received
and then once I got into podcasting it's
like an hour long people aren't people
are clicking away a little bit
and the performance did and goat
somewhat down so we're we're uh we're
back on the hunt to get up there but a
crushers a crusher dude and I think that
you're gonna really help the whole thing
that's good you know the other thing is
like I don't know how often you're
posting but why you're if you're doing
that podcast once a week
dude the the audience will come on the
audio side's building I think the word
we're averaging around like 400,000
impressions per podcast that's great are
you talking about that's great good you
have ads on your shows yeah we have we
do an ad read one or two that's great
yeah right on brother dude I appreciate
you so much Tom if I I appreciate you I
want to tell you that your your
appearance on your mom's house podcast
was an absolute joy I learned I felt
like I learned so much about you I even
told you you know I always thought I was
like this was just some [ __ ] psycho
lunatic and then having a podcast with
you and getting to to get to know you
and learn how your mind works and how
it's everything is so much more like
methodical and thoughtful it was really
eye-opening you know it was really
eye-opening so I appreciate you men I'm
a big fan well I hate likewise man
likewise and and it was there it was an
honor it was a treat I really enjoyed
that and I appreciate it dude big thanks
to Tom Segura and of course even bigger
thanks to you for hanging in there and
listening until the very end you know
I'm just super grateful for you guys
you're the street team man and let me
know that when you shoot a tech actually
no street team I cannot go through this
community app and what should I call it
and like pick out isolate keywords so if
you text say text hashtag streets team
to that number I'll give it to you again
it's 3 2 3 5 7 7 6 9 5 2 and my street
team people this is fun man text just
hashtag Street team and then I'll have a
whole group of
see you guys and I'll make you guys
first first [ __ ] yeah cool man stoked
thanks everyone